juicy Craig still has the energy for a
game of table tennis with her
grandchildren
we are completely hopeless in spite of
not getting home from the police station
until 2:00 in the morning
the 71 year old was arrested and accused
of obstruction during the environment
demonstrations in central London in the
80s Lucy took part in the Greenham
common nuclear weapons protests she says
she's never been afraid of flouting the
law for what she believes is right well
I love this planet it's my only home and
I've got grandchildren you see what I
mean I've got grandchildren who've all
got friends we've got a whole generation
of peers and I worry about them and what
they're going to be witnessing as they
grow up I mean I find it hard enough to
witness the the terrible things that are
going on around the planet places where
people's subsistence farming is dying
out because there's no water because
things are being eroded then they can't
grow crops and they can't feed their
animals extinction rebellion was
launched in October last year it was
born out of another group called the
rising up campaign this was supporters
recreating the group's symbol on a beach
in Turkey in Mexico followers march to
the mantra no more plastic from India to
Africa there have been similar protests
the founders of extinction rebellion
come from a diverse background
Raja Han well is an organic farmer and
PhD researcher from King's College
London Clare Farrell is a fashion
designer
Simon Bramwell a former builder and dr.
Gayle Bradbrook has a PhD in molecular
biophysics
today to ask for people to reflect on
the harm that we've done at Waterloo
Bridge we found two friends who'd been
inspired to travel to London from
Gloucestershire because of dr. Brad
Brookes words talking about the polar
caps melting and food shortages imminent
in this country even though they've
already been present in countries around
the world
the bad effects of climate change when I
saw a talk my heart just broke getting
arrested is certainly a story to tell
the grandchildren but it's for their
sake people like Lucy say they're taking
action Lisa Holland Sky News